[Music]
all right welcome to puzzlers paradise
Karen's favorite class does their
reminds her of gangsta's paradise right
she won the ions as puzzlers so there
you go
okay and so some reason Karen is puzzled
all right so last week the puzzles were
too hard and people left crying and I
heard you were crying at home are you
still crying or it was good okay perfect
so they'll be slightly easier this time
but always like just slightly just like
okay so let's go to let's go to the tape
okay this is actually a game I think
it's not a puzzle it's actually happened
okay I like that instead I think about
half the puzzles today were actual games
I didn't just make them up a story game
okay so it's just that nice that's good
okay and you still don't know the answer
I only can west that's grandma chicken
with all we said Western eyes look at
this before but I syllable all that you
learn with the interest okay so this is
like to play and I was just giving a
long lesson to a very strong student and
I explained as a student that a lot of
being good at chests is figuring out
what your opponent wants to do okay and
then my opponents don't do that I do
whatever I want
okay for example I wanted to get this
thing from Starbucks I wanted to teach a
class at get paid when the chancel
didn't know this I got everything okay
now
this position white wants to play Queen
g7 mate with advantage let's pretend
white makes the obvious move we have six
threatening Queen g7 me then black will
play even can list got it okay but if I
couldn't like Queen to F a then Queen f6
would be good okay and I put all the
puzzles on engines so you're not tripped
because what happens a lot is some
Grandmaster highfalutin thinks these
tall and was looking like Eric can
is walks in shows the puzzle turns out
they're 70 inches is the answers wrong
that's never happened to him but could
my imaginary world so what I do is I
engine check all the puzzles and make
sure the answer is correct and there's
that 7m trees now in this puzzle which I
learned about which I think was a game
eventually the move that's correct is
something like plus 8 that would be
winning and every other move is like
plus 0.1 so I was like ok this only has
one yes now if your opponent wants to
refute Queen f6 with Queen f8 even can
less those the answer now you just said
Queen I thinks it's a queen f8 you can
stop it you can do it you can go to the
board and physically hold the Queen
Orlando one using know you don't play
Queen FA clean air six is good mm-hmm
you try to restructure hallway I know
about you
why can't why season what woman I in yes
sir rutila's C is he right there like
hen let's set it so I don't know the
camera man likes it it's not even been
Simon that's why you can't hear me ok so
the correct answer is unfortunately CAD
West is right okay Rick c5 yeah now
clean f8 is difficult to play you could
do it but six of the agree minister like
me yeah now White's going to do some of
this stuff and black has a lot of good
defenses like resigning but you don't
have to believe me
you can tell me what you would play with
black he has a true thirds so when your
opponent has a good move it might be a
good idea to prevent it it was so easy
why didn't you solve it before rook c5
was the only who have you thought oh he
said obstructs well actually he did yeah
you know will offset obstruction it's a
trump Joe yeah ok
so yeah the computer says something like
plus eight which means it's not me but
White's going to yeah I'm guessing like
in my imaginary world if I play Queen f6
here because life doesn't get to move
that black has to play King f8 and then
I would play rook d7 like I'd would
because that stops King e7 and then I
don't know it looks like everything's
made so I'm not sure why the computer
doesn't announce mate here I know why no
no I know
ka-ching ka-ching ka-ching
that's the Ken West we know in one when
you play ka-ching and rip G now movement
release that's the Ken West we love
hopefully he picks that up okay oh all
right but I think if I take this rock
and then you can never meet me so you'll
just get up a queen for a rock that
sounds like a bug plus a yeah okay so
Rick c5 winning no other move wins and I
believe it was played in the game and
then the next puzzle this is also a game
now listen the puzzles are games okay
this is White's to play and Ken why
should solve this because white is down
a piece so Ken West is at home he's like
down a piece I windows all the time
so what I did was I looked at about a
hundred puzzles today and the ones that
I couldn't solve in one second those are
the ones you're doing if I saw them in
one second I didn't like that and there
was one I actually couldn't us all I was
like that will show them okay I solved
this one that actually took me a while
like taking me like 12 seconds stick
Orlando's quicker than me
Queen age three with two threats may
flat right and cliche Kirk's also good
although to be honest with you
stopping queen h7 makes tough I only see
one way to do it I guess they don't
think they're right otherwise Queen
seven makes pretty good which also
defends the work at stop both front
pretty good move and our labels on that
we need seven check King goes somewhere
will say here and then you win the Queen
yield skewer
that's what Ken Wes was thinking yeah
and this is sort of a this puzzle you
better solve it because if you don't
play Queen h3 you're down to 90 so it
just turns out because the Queen is
undefended on p8 and the lesson I just
gave to my very high rated student I
explained to them you should always be
looking at what's defended on the board
and what's not because the things that
are defended occasionally you can take
them when you take things that are
defended who cares you can take back so
the knight is defended a lot right by
the Queen in the rook and so you want to
take the rook and the Queen and I could
basically spend about a chest position
this ever happens you want to can work
in the Queen and Queen h3 threatens the
rook and then it turns out the only
defense loses the Queen because of where
the Queen is that's too bad unless you
have a white pieces that's great
and then Kos fails to win the waiting
endgame but we had two points for
working
Seconal okay now this one is special
okay now I'm gonna tell you why it's
special about two weeks ago ish which
for you and almost like four weeks ago
if we're lucky
anyways I didn't see this puzzle and
somebody posted on the Internet
looks our answer is wrong there's
another answer and they posted their
other answer that I posted I said that
message is no good so the recitation of
the answer was long and the answer they
get was right and then there were like
oh and these players were very good at
chat they were IMS and they're like oh
this one's quicker sorry and when that
other one so the puzzle was fine and the
reputation of the answer was long so I
guess chess is hard this is a gaze to
discuss okay so this is white to play
and win white phone look pretty good
right so these positions are usually
difficult even for grandmasters but it's
easier for a grandmaster when we're told
like to play and win that we can do it
if we weren't told that we'd be like too
hard so why is two ways to win this
endgame one is checkmate which always
wins and one is to promote a pawn or
your point doesn't
you can pause your video at home even
though it's the same is not under that
you could get a sandwich like our
cameraman when that's a piece of pizza
from where yeah it doesn't sound good
although I do like UT yeah is it that's
true I agree there you can heat that up
but that was a waste valuable second
sort of like we're doing is alright so
obviously they when they're in the
internet worlds and Heath can they see
those words too yeah
what I just I just put up work three
more oh they see this they don't see
they don't see nothing and about you
here
there's later here you can see if I mean
really look at the right answer so I
guess so okay usually what I'm teaching
like the one o'clock class you know I'm
talking about I turn all the lights down
because I don't know what's in those kit
okay so white once the play Eliza cane
all the way up there and Queen and made
them so the first move is relatively
obvious illegal
look around it's white on the bottom you
have the right answer oh yeah
what v3 is also illegal I t's good you
mean King III is a king bee
we're don't you i king b3 that's correct
you're moving towards your pawns and
you're stopping his advanced fun great
okay and black makes the Queen and white
plays King C for now black only has one
Musa lose all the funds losing all your
funds is bad for taking notes write that
down can the Westies if he's not talking
what's the only move that stays your
epon a five now if you go take the e
pawn your it's going to be black to play
it way too bad the truth hurts
luckily the King moves like a knight so
we can take it
Auto then then black would play King
takes c6 everyone which depends ba okay
now 85 has a fatal flaw noticed by an
eagle-eyed ken west eagle i-10 west i
make an album it's gonna be called man
okay what is a 5-2 that's bad for black
as good that you queen but it gives away
something something important b6 if i
play king b6 you will not be happy
because i'm going to make your next move
with c7 and the starting position I
could never play king these things
however if I take your pawn you're also
not going to be happy so you gotta do
something okay now this is the position
in question and the reason I do they
were wrong about their reputation of her
own answer was and after than me in the
tournament game against miles artemon in
the world open about 20 years ago miles
Arnhem is about
under of USCF now is about 20 to 30 USC
oh that's neither when you get older
Chan
okay so he thought he was winning and he
did a very similar thing against me and
when I need this one he was like oh and
here's applause so it reminded me of
their reputation and now as you all have
noticed Eagle Eye the King gets to be
six two different ways and one of them
wins and one doesn't
and the people who published the study
they were like oh they both win and the
only Disney say wins quicker and I said
the one you didn't say doesn't win and I
show them why they went on a blizzard
computers of Texas I already knew
because I already had this so one of
those moons wins and one doesn't
and yet to calculate your favorite thing
to do right you stopped eating his beats
because it's calculate also gone
remember what does your opponent want to
do so if you play king b5 and or king c5
in with your opponent has to stop king
d6
they have to otherwise clicking visa so
they're going to play king c7 and or
King ace admin so now you're going to
figure that out and then pick which one
king c5 or King d5 we can follow I'll
give you a minute this isn't going to
drink itself
how you doing at home good you get
something to drink now they're fun
we have a vote in the back piece the man
what's the answer
okay and so what about king c5 instead
like a voiceless king c500 obliged to
everything you said was correct
everything you do the most correct when
you play king b5 and he plays king c7
you play King aces it's over if you play
king c5 he plays cc seven and you can do
anything right okay
so King b5 is correct okay and if you
play king c5 they thought that I don't
confused Katie for King be Forsman oh
that's the move I was showing you before
if you to show me the losing move that I
showed you so it showed me okay hey
computers because I'm old
alright so if you play king c5 then
White's threatening this and you play
king c7 for some reason the Internet's
people they only looked at that move
boo then after here's over like that was
getting the analysis so they just like
forgot about king c5 the truth hurts a
king c7 I should say um okay so we
played king b5 with the sole reason to
prevent King see sadly because of king
c7 we go here and then all of you can
win right ten less is noddings I guess
so
okay so therefore black plays is the
play king c7 he was looking asa right
okay now it looks like White's being
stupid
because now white plays and we didn't
buy the last 12 Kings c5 you're like
wait a minute you told me king c5 was
wrong that you play King b5 King c5 and
you're all furious
the reason king c5 was wrong was what
you said by plays king c7 I don't think
by placing c7 here so we for sliced the
move away from c7 then we play king c5
okay so black makes the Queen because
making a queen is good right if you
retreat then I queen would check and you
don't clean so I win so you play e2 and
since it's a puzzle you get made at the
end Queen versus queen and now it's up
to you to prefer Queen b7 or Queen b6
I'm not going to judge you you're all
going to like Queen b6 between b7 is
easier it's one cleared to the tail when
all you guys are like vb6 that's the
bait I know I've never seen those are
made for the primary five crazy okay and
then mate for you guys okay but in this
position it's key to fight King b5 and
what's funny is the people who made the
puzzle who showed the refutation they
don't understand their own puzzle they
didn't make the puzzle that you showed
it the point of King b5 is to force the
King j7 so after king c5 you can't play
king c7 but they got so convinced that
black would play king a7 in response to
king b5 which is correct but they
thought he would also do that here and
then white wins easily quicker than the
other one and black should play can last
what's your black play what should he
find I will see ya King c7 yeah
why's the door oh look what's going on
here now we're talking you didn't bring
me any money or drinks exactly okay okay
so that was a women for white but he had
to be a little sneaky and used to go the
internet we can give you okay this is
the easiest of all the puzzles I gave
you guys a break I either showing us
I've been easier all right first of all
I don't know the answer to this question
but I still know the answer the question
is what opening is this it has to be a
French either a winner whare McCutchin
this is the window of a country I don't
know I'll never know
because when the cup shut off the black
place C 4 + B 5 + 8 5 and I was a little
boy what could be more we'll never know
because I don't know what this games
from okay so wife's attacking with all
pieces arrays for white but that's up a
piece so this should be a Ken white
specialty wipes down a fees so he's in
his home territory okay white to play
and win nobody tells you you're winning
when you're fighting a tournament you
just lose Orlando solves an hour ago
he's never been so proud yeah I didn't
want to look at anymore he's too happy
Ken West will solve in an hour yeah he's
like a man you were crushing as soon as
you come in ok we have a you if you play
great every move you were like
increasing your advantage
what did I call him will you okay
Arjun let's say Arjun executed yeah
thinking about Julia Shetty instead of
our journey I guess I'm shedding out of
walk I'm like he wasn't beating actually
shiny that's which I mean you can play
all right so anybody but Orlando solve
it nobody else to take info it's too
hard for them this is called based on my
life and works over works
it's an overworked puzzle let's use
texting all this the right answer Wow
anyone Bueller it does
let's see your analysis like has one
legal ooh right so this your taser are
you come down eyes like has one legal
move mister g8 would so keep going oh
you were done well allow me to retort a
discreet don't sue me pulp fiction
see your your firm used to usually
sacrifice too little this is a big we
sacrifice big stuff and anyone can watch
all the answers I'm kidding
hey any you guys know I have about two
easy
nativism what what's the answer we
that's what Ken West was thinking and
clean age six check yeah but he could
block that's thanks to Queen and Ken
West is shocked that this is me you
can't believe it he's like me too but
that's me yeah it looks like it was by
doubt it
yeah Bishop g7 is made but there's an f5
so clean h6 that begs the question does
this win brilliantly but takes longer
don't know the answer to that I'm going
to say yeah so that was meeting to with
Queen h6 but this looks like it wins -
that's even cooler because next week
next remove all ages from daily play
Bishop f7 you could play Queen c2 check
what a horrible answer yeah so Queen h6
and remission of g7 mate now can watch
that his next game you'll have that
tactic ready for your next game at any
age 6 then this won't be meeting I'll be
like what so one of my good friends
bought your phony like co-wrote my smith
worbla clip he was playing in Kings
Island open before you were all born and
he played a really long combination to
beat a better player and here's the end
of the combination he sacked his Queen
and then the guy took it and then he
plays a knight for quitting the Queen
back and he's off like a couple pieces
and then when the guy took his Queen he
said to check and suppose like what so
he couldn't play his knife for cuz he
was in check but his combination didn't
work yeah so it worked except that
didn't work as he was in check yeah
mansion like you do this and the guy
takes it says chat like we don't like
this room chief end of man
if the guy does say check you say check
please
all right this one I could not solve I
was very embarrassed if you're at home
and kidding I solved it this is a game
between two super GM's I believe Yvonne
Tchaikovsky but I could be wrong
probably not wrong though please right
Detroit lights to play I looked at it
for over a minute I couldn't solve it so
I'm is embarrassed but in my opinion con
ski wouldn't have played whatever he
just plays if he had seen it so I'm in
good company like whites winning year
and I think of cops he had seen it he
wouldn't have allowed this that means
two of us you can see it yeah you guys
are low rate of the nut so you can solve
Queens exhibition leads to me for black
he hid away into the supply part he was
like wait what oh no CAD West's gonna
meet me BAM see my queen going here
yeah also when you said the hula thought
you were right and I was like there's
two inches I computer these what ten
less there's the computer then I thought
better of myself and I figured it out
Wow and if you play clean things Bishop
you'd be very happy and so Ricky's
choosing you like way tonight what's
that fight check for now look at Cosby
threatening me all happy yeah I didn't
realize if it's left to move black
Pfizer case chewing wins know
everybody's winning well it's White's
move okay then what do i fire yep
otherwise you meet me then why keep
analyzing you can do it and this is all
getting on the audience ah Ken West
knows all right it's Queenie a chat and
the idea is to say x-ray yeah which is
not as good as ear a Z is to better than
X so you check you can't take the Queen
because rip takes is going to be made
after here the rook is hanging and the
truth any suffer case to me he's so
lucky you mind Chuck yeah you don't we
call you've unshut lucky that's what we
call him no we don't call him
yeah so he played Queen e8 and probably
cost you didn't see Queenie
so in Queenie has played his loyal like
oh man I'm kind of ski what's going on
around here
yeah exactly yeah this is really nice
clean I didn't see their work was saying
when I was trying to solve it I'm not as
good scum Lester
okay that was a nice puzzle I thought
okay now this one is silly and I solved
it in two seconds but I like the answer
because it's like geometric let's Y
solve it quickly so as you all know if
somehow white gives us negative way for
the pawn even by sacrificing his Knight
it's two knights against the king so
it's a draw so all you do is take that
pawn that's all we got to do and you can
attach upon every move
III have faith in you so I think this
one's harder than the next one the next
one I couldn't solve this is one I
solved in one second I brought some
brain malfunction
you know I think this is yeah like you
solved it can West if you solved it I
quit other way you said it like of
course
alright 97 is correct yep
ken west you cannot check your own King
og but it was good for the crowd so yeah
we might owe your king was gonna come up
and yeah well now you know what we call
great minister Ken West you thought I
was funny yeah what does that drink you
got really Wow
alright but you're still right that's
how good that's why you're Grandmaster
that is the right mood although it's not
check okay so black has one moves you
can take the pod absolutely keep going
keep it tacking it yeah
one move keep it to acting it you can do
it right okay now if you make a queen if
then you for picking employees as you
pointed out
right absolutely so you have to make a
knife okay
and now this is this is the funniest
move of the puzzle
so you can be making the three hands I
can do it
now I can't prove that I'm right for the
head can I let you prove them right but
I do believe four nights beats of
Queenie well I think it's ever happened
yeah
what move that's the hard part yeah yes
six that's a fork yeah
if he takes your night either way
excelled in here yeah I saw that one
quickly because I I saw how cute that
was and had to be right it had to be
this this this this of the night and
Anatomy yeah I computer de su computer
agree with everything it was like blacks
winning that's like all wait and then
it's Felicis always oh yeah yeah yes
tell me itself always look for stealing
when you got nothing
okay Ken West knows I'm talking about oh
yeah all right and the last one I
couldn't solve and I didn't understand
and I understand it and I feel like an
idiot I mean I solved it immediately oh
man looks pretty simple now I was
surprised that the answer that there was
only one answer
so I engine and yep so the engine
announces me and it says all of it was
are equal and the computers talk these
problems would be tougher like a hundred
years ago I can't check nothing
by following my advice as a trance coach
you could easily solve this I'm serious
I'll give you the biggest thing ever
that should give you the answer when
you're playing chess you always want to
look for what your opponent wants to do
in this position if you were black and
it was your move what would you do
you only have one who check into the
move let's hear some algebraic location
Rick f1 chat is the only move and then
if you play like let's say King a2 then
Rick a1 check someone bad or maybe I
played look at hey it could be work a
fade okay one check cannot rotate once I
can be three Rick a3 should draw should
yeah yeah okay I think we're cast one
checking a to work a one check drawers
anyway work out one check building would
you make any other than I'm gonna win
I guarantee it under the wing you look
like it one whom you see upsetting
Kenneth
well we're judgy ones checked then I
have to play King age seven and then you
let me out I'm out you're not tying me
down like you're tying you down no tied
me down lets us allow it
are you mending head out ah there's
children here come on what are you
talking about Oh
he - okay work a1 and then white panther
we're killing three yeah I mean yeah you
could ask any of my wives any other
right you agree Ken Oh terrible I give
them the answer and nothing so you know
your what must apply work out one check
so you stop it I'll give you a hint
you can stop 25% of it that's good
enough and you can allow the other 75%
managers used the more my given the
facts they didn't want that now I really
I asked the DA about this problem he
said it was very very very hard
yeah that was the set of the English
language me marry that the one guy made
fun of the wrong guy
now breathe down the move rook F lunch
at is the four five
rook F one check that's more parts and
what 25% of it
that's 25% that's non 25% they're
screaming at home get you here than like
those of the Imps and the futures are
screaming 25% you're getting rid of this
chatter it forgot one wasn't check that
wouldn't be a good move you're playing
work f1 business check not just one of
my work as one
yeah Ken let's know that I'm talking
about King a 2 and now you have to get
your rook away because we're guys one is
in check so that I can play anything
with your work well guess that energy
one now you can move your in Wing Chun I
mean Goods long they're still confused
in the audience you don't have to be
confused you can suggest a move for
black rare case that protects would you
look
he degrees now if you move your work
anywhere I put my work in front of your
ruck and you're in check if you move
your ruck here I put my work next to
your ruck and you're in check the only
one you could make with rook f1 check I
can't play her g1 double check why could
especially the 1 o'clock class now
they'd like that minima go rook takes
King this should take skiing yeah
when Esther King 82 black has to move
his rook since his King can't rule and
Rick g8 which doesn't lose a rock but
this was a rock
yeah actually don't have mate here but I
can go rook anywhere here and you have
to block with your rock I think with
addition
all right go take and then take with the
replay to let's check see if he needs to
feeling with the wins computer sense
though that was likewise King 82 and I'm
like oh there's a look at one chen likes
holy move are yeah so I was wondering
like why doesn't this win
I mean I was like okay look f1 checked
its checked so if life doesn't have any
checks except this one we don't we don't
care about that check as we check it
into the tournament but we can't check
when he plays recap 1 we can't check
from other side we've to go
so can watch this play Thu all day
that's what we call them a z10 lesson
all day can right yeah let's King hu all
day and let's see who's on the ball
what's this called what would you
classify this in a book
what's the it one just kind of puzzle
that's what I would do salon looking h2
your move and then you should write the
boolean Simpsons aha it's your move but
you don't want to move also wife doesn't
want to move here I think every white
move allows a chat right if I move my
dish of there's rook F to check in
saying if you play Bishop g4 I still
play Rick Epps you check because if you
take my look I take your look so every
Tate every move that white plays here
allows a chat and you want to keep your
work on g7 so you're ready to play some
discovered check yeah be careful for
stalemate
you got a watch yeah so King aid to that
was tough for me it was tough for you
and that can lock it is all day so to
solve puzzles and to play even in
regular chest it's not a puzzle but the
answer looks like a puzzle you always
have to see what your opponent wants to
do and be ready for that what most kids
do in the kids class and all of adults
do and chest camps and such I show them
a puzzle and they raise their hand and
they asked me if their answer is right
they're like the ship c3 and I'm going
well you're not solving that you're
asking me and when you suggest to move
in a puzzle you have to be giving me
some variation like I think my opponent
will go here and this is why I'm winning
but they're just like is this right
I mean it could be right but that
doesn't mean that you're right as you
said one of the legal moves if you said
oh we've got one checkers black hole we
move their 1482 that's not like a
stronger image to explain that wouldn't
say as a king Hz webinar and I would be
like no then do like Aria I guess he's
right
yeah now I didn't give one move because
I was being nice
we have some time left so this is only
for Ken West
the an oh snap
joining the Chess Club $100 a year Ken
white space priceless what do you do
very mr. yeah you move the rook anywhere
yeah well not anywhere anywhere except
g8 a seven here also good right but you
don't take that look so watching you
read all right that was puzzlers
paradise now you can all go home and
list of the gangster's paradise and
compare right and then if you want to
like if you're done with that that was
the Amish paradise bye there you go then
let's do some in there right yeah all
right so if you're Amish I'll see you
guys next week bye
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]